there's a new brand on the scene called
alif they make 100 halal raw cat food
there are countless health benefits to
this new raw diet check them out on
instagram at alif dot uk they do monthly
subscription boxes and you can get 10
discount on their two week trial box
with my code ali10 check them out now
and let your cat enjoy some nice food
assalamu alaikum whatever you better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends uh i was planning on doing this
video actually a very long time ago you
know when the first incident happened so
what i'm about to mention to you is
things that actually happen and i want
to mention my disappointment um and why
am i disappointed you're going to find
out so in
2018 uh 25th of december um i was in
tooting i was doing a turn um to
basically doing kind of a u-turn um a
brother who was parked up he just um he
didn't put his lights on but he just
came out the parking place as i was
turning in uh the front of our cars kind
of touched bumped to each other yeah
so obviously muslims there was a young
brother who came outside and i said
sorry et cetera you know i didn't see my
name i didn't know he had his lives when
he was parked up after he stayed
stationary so we didn't see anyways but
he just said yaki you know i've seen
some of your videos
we swap numbers and i said aki check the
dash cam see if it's my fault i'm
willing to pay i'm willing to pay the
damages you know it's totally fine you
know i have no issues with that if i'm
wrong i will pay
so anyways um there was some
miscommunication uh but from what i
remember in that house uh in the car
there was a young boy and uh the
brother's sister was in the back that's
all i know
so next thing i know is that um i'm told
that um the father of the brother is
going through insurance now i spoke to
him and i said we don't need to go for
insurance because firstly there's no
damage yeah and no one's
injured yeah so he said oh you know i
tried to speak to my dad you know he's
not listening et cetera et cetera et
cetera
and next thing i know is i get a
notification from my um
insurance company saying that there are
four people in the car four or five
people in the car and they are all
injured
so when i heard this i was thinking
really like i was like is this for real
and i got contact and i said brother i
said this is what i got what like what's
going on you know what you mean there's
four or five people in the car there's
like four or five people in the car yeah
and four or five adults yeah there was
the information the the kid and you're
telling me that there's people injured i
said okay this is haram you're lying
someone is lying here nobody was injured
and there was no significant damage
so he said to me aki you know my dad
he's not listening to me that i said
subhanallah i said your name is in there
you know anyways this went for a bit of
a while etc and i i said i had the dash
cam as well i said this is it's a fruit
you know
it's a fraudulent claim and i let them
know and to this day what i know is that
the brother dropped out i think he
thought about it and i thought it's not
worth it yanni lying for something so he
dropped out the case has gone to a
foreign case it's gone to that kind of
uh
levels where nobody got nothing
you you lost in this life you know and
when i'm in specific instantly with this
thing and then in the hair after you're
going to be questioned now forget that
um october 2019 uh 14th of october 2019.
i'm driving and next thing i know is
someone with a range rover just pulls
randomly in front of me and i hit him
my car gets written off okay it wasn't
even necessarily my car it gets written
off
next thing i know is this uh
another brother he's afghani they're
both afghanis and by the on the generals
i'm saying this is an afghan issue by
the way yeah i'm not saying that let's
just make that clear
the problem is afghan afghani himself
and he said sorry bro this start i
didn't see i said it's fine it's no
problem but my car's written off just
have to go for insurance that's it and
he said yeah no problem i'm insured but
don't worry etc all this kind of stuff
uh reassuring me blah blah blah next
thing i know
i'm trying to get in contact with him
because he has no insurance on the car
can you imagine he's got no insurance my
car's written off i had to go through my
own insurance yeah and um
the brother who owns the car got paid
out
now
thirdly this this is where i got really
triggered yeah this is where i got
really really triggered
this happened 25th of november um 2021
yeah a couple of months ago
i'm stationary a motorbike an uncle on a
motorbike comes in between me and the
island which you know what motorbikes do
they go in between cars
he pulls up right in front of me we're
both stationary
and the
the stand they use for the bikes there
to keep it you know when it's stationary
that hooked onto my bumper and ripped it
off
now i want you guys to watch this
footage watch this footage and we're
going to come back because and i'm going
to tell you why i'm so annoyed through
insurance haven't got time for this but
the thing is not my car
you know
what what question is it what is it
no no no no it's fine but what kind of
stuff
what stuff does it this did this get
stuck
no no what
what pulled it out i don't get it
can you put that in there
i think
[Music]
no no i know but i'm going straight and
that thing
it was very tight and it hit
look i don't want to go for insurance i
don't have time
i just need this fixed that's my
competition because it's not my part
it's a
wrench
how can i hit you because you're pulling
it off if i hit you you will have damage
this way because i'm hitting you i'm
scraping you you're pulling this off
that means something is hooked
okay okay
tell me how
i crash into you and this bumper comes
off okay
because of the five
is
[Laughter]
okay
[Music]
honestly
you're going to say your leg is injured
and your leg is not injured i have to
call my doctor i have to treat myself
everything no no no no no
you scraped me i didn't touch you
but how was you looking into it
i have to then you're saying you have to
so as you can see guys
if i hit if i hit him
guys you saw that footage for yourself
yeah i'm hiding the brother's identity
uh this uncle's identity and i'm gonna
try to be as respectful as i can
i get a message and in this instance i i
said i would have to go for insurance
rather just pay for my bumper and he's
telling me i'm letting you off i'm
thinking how are you letting me when
you've ripped my bumper you've took my
bumper off yeah
anyways next thing i know is for
insurance injury claim and in the video
you can see me telling him brother you
cannot lie
because you did not get injured and
there's nothing wrong with your bike you
just hooked my uh bumper and ripped it
off i'm just saying if you can put the
bumper in fix it 50 100 whatever it is
that's all i'm asking for
i was going to go down the insurance
route i said forget it yeah i don't have
a
i want to get no claim bonus i thought
forget it i can't be bothered he's a
muslim i'm getting a message from the
insurance saying the third party is
doing a claim against you for injury
and damages to the vehicle
now the reason i'm doing this is because
i know many many muslims who are
involved in this yeah
wallahi brothers and sisters
just recently actually i got into
another accident yeah okay
and somebody um hit my car from the back
in the on the motorway yeah like
literally bang yeah
do you not think i can i can make three
four thousand pounds about injury my
neck broke yeah my neck is not working
at my tyson said you know i broke my
back spine oh yeah i couldn't make up
stuff i was like i'll get four five
grand why would i want haram money
number one why would i lie
why am i gonna lie and say oh my back is
certain exception no i am not injured
i am not injured why should i lie you
know what this shows a lack of tawakon
in allah because what you're seeing is
the following i don't trust allah can
provide for me i need a couple of
thousand pounds maybe i can go on
holiday whatever and i'm going to lie
you something that is destined to you
you aren't in a haram way and lying not
only that man i'm a muslim yeah this
uncle i messaged him i'll show you the
message on the screen i said uncle
there's
yeah to me it's
in a win-win situation to me you know
why because i know on the day of
judgement uncle you know not that i'm
gonna take it to you well i'll forgive
you the issue is deeper than that do you
not think you're gonna stand in front of
allah and you are saying you're lying
your leg is injured and on the camera
you saying clearly that you're not
injured you're saying if you go to
insurance i would i i i would say this
and that
this is
following islam
are we following islam well it makes me
sick
your believer what lie is it worth yeah
imagine
degrading yourself to a point where you
are lying about an incident that did not
happen
brothers
have trust in allah
i do not remember a day where i said you
know what how am i going to provide for
my family tomorrow
have trust in allah if you push away the
haram allah will give you five times
more the halal way
and as muslims we've dropped to a level
where we are lying to about to another
believer you shouldn't do it to anybody
it's not even a matter of muslim to
muslim you should be standing up for
truth
regardless not all some guy hit me or
whatever while he should tell you
something if my worst enemy hit me yeah
let's say april's the possibility of his
little boy one life hit me with a car
one light i'll say i'm not injured i'm
not gonna lie i'm not gonna say this guy
is my enemy so let me make la
it's a lie lie is a lie
the reason i'm doing this video brothers
and sisters is as a reminder because
while i as muslims we should know better
man
what kind of utter business if you can
do this with a muslim i would be like
what do you do with someone else oh tell
your whole family was in there oh my
great granddad was there my uncle was
there my dead
granddad was there
just so what just so we can get some
money
we need to leave this disease have trust
in allah push away the haram and watch
how allah subhanallah blesses you how he
puts barak in your life the one who's
created the heavens and the earth and
you are in doubt about
can he provide for me he provides for
the universe
universe
i'll leave it on that i'm not going to
carry on and wallahi let me tell you
something and this is going to a fourth
case as well the first one went to a
fourth case i think they dropped it i've
got nothing to lose you know what i know
i have my trust in i'm not trying to act
like you know i'm a mukmin i'ma have my
trust in allah i know the first one went
to follow the case the brother whose
that started this he dropped out they
called me and said you know this guy i'm
gonna call him brother b he dropped out
he maybe came to a sentence may allah
bless him yeah he dropped out okay the
second one is going to fall and claim uh
the one actually he didn't have
insurance yeah um and he might even get
leaked
on his own six points off his license
yeah and this one inshallah is going to
afford and claim same thing one like i
have no doubt allah will do deal with
this situation but it's just sad seeing
believers man muslims who are supposed
to be following prophet salallahu sallam
and they are indulging in these kind of
activity activities because they don't
have trust in allah it's a shame
it's ashamed this video is just a
general reminder put your trust in allah
brothers and sisters
avoid the haram
mark my words
fix your affairs with allah
allah will fix all your affairs just fix
your affairs with him have trust in him
and avoid
sins whatever it may be
till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi
[Music]